after Hurricane sandy in 2012 election
officials in some parts of America
decided they would allow emergency
electronic voting from home you would
download a ballot paper fill it out and
then email or fax it back to them and
yes some people still fax this was a
terrible idea
and here's why physical voting is
centuries old in that time pretty much
every conceivable method of fraud has
been tried Anderson's been defended
against because of that attacks on
physical voting don't scale well it
takes so much effort so many people and
it only takes one person to leak your
conspiracy and the whole thing falls
apart but electronic voting you can
attack with one person and it can take
about the same effort to change one vote
as it does to change a million and it
can be done without even setting foot in
the country whose elections you're
trying to rig there are two key parts of
an election first anonymity you cannot
let anyone pay or bribe in order to
change someone's rank or threaten them
if you put any identifying mark on your
paper but if you sign it put your name
on it put a number on anything that
could in theory be used to check how you
voted then your vote is thrown out just
so no one can be forced or bribed to
vote a certain way and yet because you
marked your vote and you put it into a
sealed box that box was only unsealed
when it was surrounded by everyone with
a stake in the election you know that
your vote has still been counted even
though you will never see it again
that's the other key trust or a complete
lack of it you never ever ever trust any
one individual ideally you don't trust
only two or three people can be bribed
can be threatened can be incompetent I
mean how people have been all three of
those things at the same time but like I
said the more physical votes you want to
change the more people it takes and the
less possible your attack gets everyone
can see what's happening and they can
keep an eye on each other particularly
if they don't trust the the despicable
people on the other side so let's talk
about voting machines problem number one
auditing the software and hardware
because in theory you could have open
source software that everyone has
checked and everyone is happy with and
that's been used for years
in theory never mind that you only
actually do a full-scale test of this
software every few years
there's actually an election let's say
theoretically it can be done how do you
make sure that that software is what's
actually loaded on that voting machine
in front of you on the day of the
election and I know that immediately
someone is going to want to comment
about checksums or crypto which is great
except now you have to trust the
software that's checking that hatch or
more likely the one person who is
checking it for you you have just moved
the problem and if you're thinking right
now it's fine I could verify that then
turn your brain the other way and think
how could I break that because there are
trillions of dollars it's not an
exaggeration trillions riding on the
result of big elections and that is an
incredible motivation if you're coming
up with sneaky ways to get around it
believe me so are lots of other people
now it might be one angry techie but it
might be an entire political party or
the huge corporations who want one party
to win or entire nation states who want
one party to win and all that is
assuming that you are even allowed to
verify the software that's running which
you never are because plugging unknown
USB sticks into a voting machine is a
bad idea
not that stops people plugging unknown
USB sticks into a voting machine it has
literally happened let's remember these
machines have to be left in a room with
the voter and no one else in order for
the votes to cast their vote anonymously
on by the way the machines are
frequently programmed by sticking a USB
into each of them in turn so if you
compromised the first one jackpot in
practice you don't have open source
software you have proprietary unaudited
software which you just have to trust
this is real by the way around the world
there are some elections that run on
this and remember what I said this is an
election you don't trust and maybe
you're thinking ok you can have an audit
trail you can have a paper backup that
the Machine prints out as you vote in
which case congratulations
you have just invented the world's most
expensive pencil one of the reasons
Britain gives people pencils for voting
by the way is because we're worried that
pens might be switched by any voter to
contain disappearing ink it might be an
urban legend sure but if you want to do
something like that then in raising
pencils way more difficult in just
putting disappearing ink in there might
be an urban legend might be a plausible
attack vector that's the level of
paranoia we're working out here and if
you think that you can get away with all
this by using a pile of paper ballots
and just counting them electronically
an electronic counting machine is still
a black box that a pile of ballots goes
into and a mysterious number comes out
of they've got exactly the same problems
problem number two votes in transit
there are three ways are moving the
magic electronic ballot numbers from the
voting machines to the final count you
could treat the machine like a regular
ballot box seal it in a plastic bag move
the physical machine with two people
inside the vehicle to the count and then
you unseal it there no one does this you
could copy the result onto a handy USB
stick and move the USB stick instead do
I need to run through how easily no okay
comma see I don't oh and this is what
usually happens you could tell the
voting machine to upload the results
over the Internet optionally through a
third party central server probably not
over secure connection and probably
without any check sums or tests from
number three the central count program
right at the end there is the program
that takes all these numbers all these
votes and produces a final count so now
you have all the same problems that you
have with the individual voting machines
except now only a few people can even
see that computer and it's been hidden
away in a private warehouse somewhere
for the last few years so you know good
luck verifying that and all this all
this is before we even talk about online
voting and you could talk about all the
ways you could hijack ballots you can
compromise computers you could block an
email address because after Hurricane
sandy the ballots were sent by email I
any of the ways you could do a
man-in-the-middle attack on any of that
all possible all entirely possible and
those are just fits a well designed
system there are reports of actual live
elections whether a cross-site scripting
attacks in the e-voting page where they
misspelled one party's name where they
put the wrong party's logo next to a
candidate so did I say elections I meant
election that was all the same election
and it was one of the trials in
Hampshire in 2007 but never mind all
that depending a which security company
you believe somewhere between 5% and 50%
of desktop computers around the world
are infected with something that's just
the scammers trying to set up botnets
and minor extortions on private
computers if you want to affect a load
of votes try infecting the computers at
the public library but never mind that
because we've seen what some big scary
countries and big scary corporations can
do when they put their mind to it
given that someone someone designed an
immensely complicated worm that spread
around the world just to break some
Iranian centrifuges imagine what someone
could do if they wanted to throw an
online election remember when you hear
just trust us or just trust me or it's a
computer it doesn't go wrong in an
election something has already gone
disastrously wrong imagine all this
electronic voting only without computers
would you be happy walking up to someone
anonymous and a ballot box or worse just
calling someone on your phone telling
them your vote but they promise to keep
it secret at the end of the election all
those people have been sitting on their
own phone up one other person in private
and tell their results and then that
final person who promises to count it
all up accurately just announces who's
won because that is essentially what
electronic voting is it is a terrible
idea and if a government ever promises
to use it
hope they don't manage it before you get
a chance to vote them out well that's
the problem in film yeah CT man cuz you
can they rattle emic rattle s'en and is
massive tray of whatever it is is moving
between that and the bagpiper and the
sirens we've pulled in front of a clock
there can be some patent who is going to
run through this and work out how many
takes we've done and what all our they
were in and how many times I had to
repeat that bit where I got really
flustered but a bit by the audio is all
just awful yeah never mind the fact that
I started with slightly damp hair and I
mainly with kind of Belinda Carlisle
going on here
you